Oh coffee coffee huh would be a shame if
something for a slipped a little
something is comfy with me no no no no
drink the coffee you want to drink yes
all right I did not only kill him but I
stole his sandwich and I molested his
corpse oh my god you really wanted that
sandwich you
sorry bro you can't have it you're
[ __ ] dead what oh my god how is he
not dead how are you not too dead [ __ ]
oh god what I bet what the [ __ ] does
happen everything is exploded oh my god
that's awesome that's amazing what so
weird but I mean that was weird right
your friend died but how about a donut
you love doing this right eat the donut
what what is with your voice
we're leaving no you can't tell me what
to do job have some fertilizer job man
would you like some fertilizer in your
face
boom whoa pimp it out pimp it out pimp
it out girl what the fam yes the fam
perfect perfect what do we got they try
to put the fire out huh some weed huh
research huh what grab that donut
let's try grab the donut and then
evening oh yeah baby girl I will rock
your world baby girl it's not a baby
girls an old discussing that was fun
let's do that never again